Speaker 1: If there are kids watching today.
Speaker 2: I would send them out of the room
before
Speaker 1: I play for you, what I'm going
to be playing for you right now.
I have some Kirst video and audio to play
for you today.
I don't know how many of you remember or even
knew a very strange factoid, which is that
there is a pro-Trump movement in the country
of Japan
Speaker 2: and we've during previous
Speaker 1: live streams.
I played video of these pro-Trump rallies
in Japan, some with very strange costumes
related to Trump.
It's a bizarre, bizarre thing.
But if you didn't know that, certainly in
fact, you can get through life without knowing.
But alas, there is some pro-Trump cultish
ness in Japan, and there's even an event called
C-PAC Japan.
Now, CPAC is the Conservative Political Action
Conference.
It's an event at least once a year.
I could have sworn that some years they've
done it twice.
All sorts of right wing speakers.
It's a gong show of absurdity and pabulum
for the right wing masses.
Well, there is a CPAC Japan.
The movement in Japan is so big that they
have their own CPAC.
There it was this past weekend, and this time
around, the conference had such illustrious
speakers as Jim Jordan, Mark Warner, not even
Mark Warner, who's a Democrat.
Both Mark Warner, Republican Secretary of
State of West Virginia.
Then a whole bunch of other people I've never
heard of, and I would
Speaker 2: bet money you haven't
Speaker 1: heard of either.
And Donald Trump speaking to them remotely.
Donald Trump recorded an introduction video
for the event.
It's so bizarre.
It's coerced it could give you nightmares,
which is why I say don't show this to children.
It's scarier than many horror movies.
I am sort of likening it to Silence of the
Lambs crossed with The Shining.
That's the best.
Sort of combination that I could use to describe
it, so let's look at this short clip.
See if you can pick out all the things that
are bizarre about this video.
Speaker 3: I'd like to begin by thanking everybody.
It's been so friendly to the United States.
We have an incredible relationship with Japan
and we have for a long time, I think, congratulate
Jay Iber, the head of the Japanese conservative
union.
They're working together with us and Matt
Schlapp and Mercedes Schlapp with sheep back
in the United States has been really a powerful
force.
Our relationship with Japan has been incredible.
I worked with, as you know, Prime Minister
Abe for a long time and we worked strongly
together on North Korea and on so many other
problems, including problems, frankly, with
China.
It was my honor to help our relationship in
terms of trade has doubled.
We've gone into a stratospheric mode.
It's been really rather incredible to see
what's happened between the United States
and Japan over the four years that I was the
president of the United States.
So I just like to say I hope everyone's having
a fantastic time.
You know, with my friends and you are my friends
and congratulations on your tremendous success.
I look forward to being in Japan shortly.
And when I am, I will stop by and say, hello,
have a wonderful evening.
Speaker 1: So some truly Kirst images of Donald
Trump.
The camera is so far from the guy.
Why is that?
It looks like some kind of strange horror
movie cinematography.
The audio's terrible as usual.
With these recent Trump videos, there's not
even a mike on them.
The stuff that he's producing down in Florida,
they don't even make him up.
Cameras 20 30 feet away, you can barely hear
him.
He's in a gaudy ballroom of some kind.
He's wearing a tuxedo.
He's facing the camera with his arms down
at his sides, hinging forward at the waist
the way he often does.
Everything is weird.
He's kind of twitching and making strange
body movements.
There is nothing normal about this video,
but also notable even in this strangest of
strange videos.
Donald Trump can't even tell basic factual
truths.
Speaker 2: What was the one
Speaker 1: sort of substantive
Speaker 2: element of that video? Trump saying,
We've doubled
Speaker 1: trade with Japan.
We have not doubled trade with Japan.
Does Donald Trump not realize that the data
is widely available?
Does he assume no one will care?
Does he not realize he's lying?
I don't know.
But if you look and we're putting it up on
the screen now, if you look back at the last
20 years of trade with Japan, you see that
it's actually been really steady.
In 2009, at the sort of bottom of the Great
Recession, it declined.
But otherwise, trade with Japan has been notably
steady.
There has been no doubling here, and this
is considering both imports and exports.
So what's the concern here?
Because it's very easy to laugh at Trump and
see him doing these weird videos and say,
Oh, he's just a loser past his prime and he
is, and he is tomorrow.
In fact, we're going to look at video of every
once in a while
Speaker 2: at his club,
Speaker 1: Mar a Lago.
They do weddings at Mar a Lago.
Sometimes Trump will, like, walk into a wedding,
or he'll walk into the dining room or whatever,
and he will
Speaker 2: speak to the
Speaker 1: crowd.
And often he'll start talking about the big
lie.
He'll start lying about the election or whatever.
And it's really, really weird.
Tomorrow, we're going to look at video of
Trump doing exactly that.
So it's all fun and games, and the guy's a
loser, and nobody's paying attention to him
in any kind of serious way.
But.
Every poll so far suggests that he would still
win the Democratic Party, the Republican primary,
and he would win it easily.
The only guy polling even anything of note
was Ron DeSantis when there was the most recent
straw poll.
And so as much as we laugh, it would be even
more
Speaker 2: devastating if again,
Speaker 1: the guy is able to win in twenty
twenty four too many people when it was Hillary
versus Trump said she's not going to lose.
She's got it.
She doesn't need my vote.
I'm not going to vote at all.
Or maybe I'll vote third party.
Or maybe I'll even vote.
Trump is a goof because Hillary's got it.
And look at where it got us.
Three Supreme Court justices.
Maybe the end of Roe v. Wade, one of the most
humiliating mishandling of COVID globally.
And on and on and on.
So as absurd as it is to see Trump relegated
to yelling at dinner, dinner guests at Mar
a Lago or doing bizarre videos like this.
Speaker 2: Most of the Republican
Speaker 1: Party, based on the polling we
have would put a right back where he was for
four years, and
that's a horrifying reality.